Something has changed, Geralt.
The world's acting strange
these days.
The North and South at war.
Monsters roaming
when they should be hibernating.
Maybe it's the end of days.
I've lived through
three supposed "end of days."
It's all horseshit.
This continent
was meant for no one.
None of us will have any peace…
until there are no monsters
left in the world.
It's my home.
My fight.
Your precious leader's
after something.
You're a pawn to get to it.
Rebuild our forces,
strengthen our numbers.
We are an empire.
The war's just begun.
Fear is an illness
that can consume you.
Our best chance…
is to face it.
Are you ready for this?
If what you say
about that girl's power is true,
you can't help her.
Man, myth, legend.
-We need your help.
-Fine.
But first,
gentlemen, it's been an honor.
What?
I made new friends. Get over it.
Jealous.